there was no room on the road
which wraps itself around the port of
durban
it had been turned into a thoroughfare
for raiders and thieves
as they ransacked warehouses and
distribution centers
located close to the shipping terminal
the young and the old took advantage
with people on foot
joined by those in pickup trucks who'd
come to steel
in bulk and the police and the country's
military
well they were nowhere to be seen why
are people doing this
why are people doing it the train tracks
were used as a form of escape
by those lugging stolen goods although
many tried to avoid our camera
you're hungry
it was a sentiment expressed by many
why are people looting
[Music]
no food no nothing no work he said
but you can't eat a bicycle
i can he responded the trouble was
triggered by the arrest of the former
president
jacob zuma last week but it has been
fueled by frustration in a country where
millions are struggling
in the midst of the pandemic and what
about zuma are people doing this for
zuma
uh i
i think there's no food okay
this is looting on an industrial scale
there are
hundreds of the thousands of people here
really with
bikes and furniture microwaves and
anything they can carry and the police
they're
they're really just looking on from
above this doesn't seem to be anything
they can do
the authorities have made nearly 2 000
arrests nationwide
but they are not in control
[Applause]
on the river horse industrial estate a
police unit fired tear gas
and rubber bullets in an attempt to
clear the park
[Music]
and we watched the looters flee through
clouds of smoke
although many dumped their plunder
and there are some here who will never
leave we counted three dead bodies
on the grass covered verge of the estate
highway of death gulf war that's what it
looks like down here if you carry on
further down the road
the car's burnt out red cars on the road
they've looted everything the
factories are burning warehouses are
burning the people are coming by their
thousands to come and loot
[Applause]
the police are outnumbered and
bewildered
and some are growing angry as they race
to another call
we saw one officer firing his weapon and
people on the roadside
at point-blank range
roadblocks have been erected to
intercept the looters
but they will not stop this disorder
for the authorities lack basic resources
while millions of people cannot meet
their basic
needs in a crisis that threatens south
africa
ordinary people have chosen to steal
and the implications seem unmanageable
john sparks sky news in durban